we hear you do a monkey impression oh I
wish I'd never written that down man
okay it's really it's not anything
amazing but here we go
there you go my name is Rachel and I'm
from Las Vegas and why do you want to do
Big Brother Rachel because I absolutely
love this show I've been watching it
since I was 11 years old I won't tell
you how old I am right now but I've been
watching it since I was 11 since the
first season and I know a lot of people
that watch the show are fans of the show
say they wouldn't compete in the show
but I'm a little crazy I'm a you know
I'm a performer a little out there so
this is definitely a challenge that I
definitely want to want to accept on a
scale of like novice just super fan
where would you put yourself well in the
past few years I've got a little bit a
little bit more superfan okay so I'd say
I'm at about a nine on the novice to
superfan scale I'll take it yeah and you
get to be on Big Brother twenty twists
are you hoping for this is a big season
I mean what twist am i hoping for a
twist that had helped me out to my
advantage you know I'm such a big fan of
this game it's the 20th season I'm so so
excited to be a part of season 20 so I'm
hoping I'm hoping for some big twists
again that worked to my advantage but
yeah it's big brother so I'm excited I
know it's gonna be challenging and I'm
ready for that if you had to pull from
Big Brother past somebody's game play
that you wanted to model yourself after
who's a Big Brother alum then you're
like I'm gonna play like that
well Brittany Haynes from Big Brother 12
is my favorite contestant of all time
and the reason why I love her so much is
that her social game and her physical
game was so on point I'm definitely
going to be using more of my social game
this year so I'm really hoping to model
after her she was able to use her comedy
and her wit and her humour to really
create relationships with a lot of
different people she was able to get out
of a lot of sticky situations
really hoping to model my game after her
and on the flipside is there anybody
that you're like I am for sure not gonna
play like that probably not gonna play
like Victoria okay or Shima okay they
didn't play the game very well so
probably not gonna play them like them
well speaking of Victoria not a scale of
Victoria - let's say dr. will how dirty
are you okay getting in this game
probably probably at about a four or
five okay I'm probably right around the
middle
I'm definitely want to play the game
with integrity I want to play the game
with the people that that I create bombs
and close relationships with I know at
some point I'm going to have to cut some
people that's just how the game is
hopefully I've created a good enough
relationship with them that they won't
hate me in the end and be bitter but I
know eventually it will have to be that
way because you can't go to the final
two with you know 15 other people so
yeah not too dirty but dirty enough okay
with it being season 20 who knows maybe
alums could pop up in the house is there
anybody you would love to play the game
with that I would love to play the game
with Brittany Haynes good answer
yeah Brittany or I mean I'm just trying
to think of who else I would love to
maybe Janelle I mean she was a tough
competitor but I can throw the tough
competitors in there with me as well and
is there anybody you would not want to
see in the house you don't want to see
in the house Dan he was really smart
trying to think who else yeah mainly Dan
okay I want to see Dan I think you're
safe that he said he doesn't want to
play the game well thank God thank you
all right this game show mansis happen
every summer
mm-hmm what are your thoughts on show
manses my thoughts and feelings I
definitely am down for a showmance
I do want one I'm single so I'm good
really
definitely looking forward to it if it
does happen I will not give up my game
though for a guy that's just not gonna
happen for me I'm I'm pretty when it
comes to relationships and it comes to
people I'm pretty I have a good read on
them so if it's something that's real
and it's something that I think is gonna
last outside the house I'm definitely
gonna invest my time best sometime into
it but I don't want it to be the center
in the focus so that everyone in the
house goes oh they're show mints oh
they're a pair they're together I don't
want them to to think that so I'm
definitely gonna keep my distance or try
to at least try to make it not very
threatening but yes I'm definitely
looking for looking for if it happens if
it doesn't it's okay gosh oh man game
first love clothes exactly close second
this game also has a way of bringing out
things from people's pasts they come out
it to light is there anything you're
worried about coming I'm not too worried
about it I mean I am a performer so I
guess I mean there could be some stuff
from my past I don't know but I I'm not
too worried about that and I've done a
feel like I've done a pretty good job of
covering my bases
so hopefully not all right well give you
the platform here if there's anything
you want to get out there now confess
too before you enter that house is there
anything I want to confess you know
there's nothing I want to confess I just
want to confess them a really big big
brother fan okay that's the easy thing
chicken yes exactly
is there anything that you don't want
your fellow houseguests to know about
you going in though yes I don't want
them to know that I have an acting
background because I think that that
would work to my disadvantage I don't
want them to know that I am a super fan
I don't want them I'm gonna walk in and
be like wait what wait what's it a head
of house oh okay and then oh and then
the wait veto okay okay cool so I wanted
definitely act like I'm not but not be
overall like the oka obvious but yeah
definitely I've seen a season by like
yeah like I think they made me watch
season night
whatever season 12 because it's pretty
hain so you are potentially going into
this house for three months yeah what is
the one thing you're dreading living
without the one thing I'm dreading
living without just freedom to be able
to do what I want watch TV be with my
dog go to happy hours just be with my
friends um those are the things I'm
gonna miss the freedom but I'm okay with
it right now because there's a goal
right now and I'm very focused $500,000
is there anything that you're excited to
give up for three months a person
something get back at home um well I
bashed my cell phone so I'm actually
excited to get rid of that I was like
well perfect timing uh yeah I'm just
kind of I'm ready to get away from the
world actually for a little bit I'm
ready to be somewhere else and yeah I'm
just I'm ready I was ready for that
break okay to wrap things up here why
are you gonna win big brother 20 I'm
gonna win big brother 20 because I have
all three components I have the fist I
have the physical I have the mental and
I have the social and I think definitely
the social game is going to put me ahead
of a lot of people than watching this
game a long time I feel like I'm gonna
be able to to maneuver the game very
easily hopefully so I I do think that I
have a great chance of winning awesome
well good luck hopefully the next time I
see you it's in the backyard and you've
just got to check in your head I hope so
we hear you do a monkey impression oh I
wish I'd never written it down
okay it's really it's not anything
amazing but here we go there you go Wow
where did that come from how did you
learn to think I was an acting class
somewhere and they were like be an
animal and I picked a monkey and I love
monkeys and it just came out from from
the belly and I like really tight my
core and it just came out so you gotta
use that in the house somewhere yes I do
that who are like what so yeah I'll do
it all right
[Music]